ah no job wiping the tears away because
it's good it's good TV hey what's going
on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones the show with
hot questions even hotter wings today
I'm joined by actor comedian
hello bald icon Rob Corddry enjoyer and
if you want to see Rob season 2 of
ballers returns Sundays to HBO yeah
that's right I think that you'll be good
through the first five or six but I'm
when we start to get to this area that's
what about you are you like this is
nothing for you
so I've done it so many times that I
know what to expect so you are kind of
going against a stacked deck over here
I'm already getting like the aroma of
some of these and it's probably down
here I'm just assuming it's a little bit
violent Stephen get started
first one is sriracha that's no big deal
everyday sir it's like ketchup to us
right I'm sorry this is just rude of men
so the dynamic of the daily show field
assignments have always intrigued me as
somebody who interviews people all the
time it looks like it must be so bizarre
behind the scenes to be messing with
people and then edit that together so
that the humor comes through here the
most uncomfortable thing was when I was
on the show we only had one camera we
could only afford one camera we would do
the interview first I'd be asking you
the questions and then at the very end
if we just turned the camera around over
here when I would react the questions
and that's when you can see it they
start to realize they hear the questions
the second time and they start to
realize like all I'm screwed the act of
hearing a question a second time
solidifies the reality wait a minute
is there a field assignment in
particular that kind of stands out to
you as being especially uncomfortable or
weird it was a really fun one I love the
guy but he's this doctor wrote a book on
germs and we were trying to prove how
voting booths are contaminated and can
kill you and he found we tested the
booths and he found fecal matter he's
trying to sell his book among germs and
we're just talking to him well we're
fixated on the poop and he was yelling
to his assistant like Doris get them out
of here he was having fun as well but he
realized he's probably not to sell a lot
of books let's have another wing while
we talk about I'm just a patio Tapatio
is no big deal another household name
another classic you've appeared on The
Daily Show Curb Your Enthusiasm Arrested
Development I think a lot of people
would say that those are three of the
most defining comedies of our era I'm
wondering how you pick roles is it safe
to say that you maybe go for the best
project with the funniest people rather
than being the star would that be a fair
this show is gonna be a defining show
I'm gonna to know how much yeah that's
exactly what I do I mean my only plan in
life my only real plan with my career
solid plan is to do cool stuff with with
people who aren't jerks I might not get
paid as much as I as a lot of people but
it's like it's nuts it's worth it to
like have a good time I've had this
before right it's a standard a little
less standard than those two but yeah is
it true that you were a security guard
on tomorrow yeah I watch oh my god I
have about a thousand questions about
that go you ever see anybody on a first
date are there certain things that you
can key in on yeah how do you know well
we have these nights they're their words
they would open up the roof garden and
it would be like a cocktail look at our
cuttin it was always always like almost
exclusively first dates but I think it's
kind of a lame first date that's what I
think I think you know because I think
it's a little pretentious you're trying
too hard you're trying too hard oh I
like art yeah indie than the other side
of that people take a first day to like
no let's go to Gray's papaya like my
favorite hotdog stand it's like now
you're trying too hard to be real what
sorts of issues would a security guard
at the Met have to deal with um my one
real job my only job there was to keep
people from touching art now you think
who's gonna touch the art that's what I
like everybody knows not to touch it a
lot of people really want to get their
hands on that I wish there was like a
high school class one day looking at
this famous it's like the death of
Socrates or the death of Plato which one
drank the hemlock I think it's the death
of Socrates it's like this masterwork
right and there was a guide telling
these kids about the painting and then
and some heat some kid goes which one's
Plato and this kid comes all the way
from the back and makes a loop and he
goes this one and he starts banging on
Plato and
like across the room suddenly like
moving in slow motion by gambling oh and
it had a divot in this real estate it
was a little dig on your watch and it
disappeared they had their uh yeah they
were paired off the wall because that
jerk kid well yeah they gotta pull it
off the wall there there's a ding in it
this is Louisiana style right pinky cuz
its habanero this I had think as a kick
because Nate put the sauces on and I can
tell that this is a generously sauce
episode I read it was your decision to
close the curtains on Children's
Hospital
sort of ride off into the sunset that
might have breathed in a little Hut's up
don't inhale hot sauce alright I'm good
and you said that you wanted to go out
sort of on top you know while the show
was still good close it out while the
show is still like that yeah which is
very unamerican usually usually we drive
shows right into the ground can you talk
a little bit about that this is Janice
yeah yet it really is it's like not the
way we're supposed to think about this
you know I think it's disrespectful to a
show that I love to like let it go and
die basically like let it go and become
something that no one cares about not
funny anymore and it's just like a job
to people and it was really special to
all of us there and I wanted to go out
as special so this next one is actually
our hot sauce it's the hot ones hot
sauce here on the Hoffman show oh the
hot ones fiery Chipotle get it while
it's hot we have to write you a check
for like 25 grand now right we'll work
it out so there are a lot of kids these
days stereotypes and I think that if I
were a father I'd be so worried that
like my kids playing Pokemon go on
active railroad track so they're
spending all their birthday money on
Kylie Jenner lip kits as the father of
daughters can you talk about some of the
challenges you face raising years in
2016
yeah ma'am my seven-year-old since she
was four has wanted to be a tattoo
artist and we thought oh
a cute thing for this four-year-old
child to say but she's still saying it
and she just bought like we just got her
a Fender Strat and she's playing guitar
and she was like I don't want pink I
want to keep them authentic to what they
who they are so they don't have to go
out and you know try on these different
personalities and all this other garbage
I just do what my my boy and my wife
does what does he wife - she's good at
it I just copy her mmm whoa that one you
just hit him up with the high river
Rover I believe though let me add a kick
yeah that one was way more intense than
that one I know that you're a big Howard
Stern fan well go ahead and everyone has
their favorite whack Packers and the
ones that they don't like so much and I
was hoping I could just bounce a couple
off going yeah you could give me the
first kind of comes to your matter what
you think of them okay then my favorite
job to do that comes back it stucks it
yep it's got a little uh yeah a place
for you taunting me right now Jeff the
drunk I could do without him how about
Beetlejuice yeah Beetlejuice fan he's
the best he's my favorite I'd say what
about a Bigfoot like Bigfoot yeah anyone
that they can prank they can prank call
with uh with their own voice and that's
a Class A that's immediate when they got
Bigfoot's like try to fight himself yeah
a [ __ ] is I am NOT a
[ __ ] huge me what awesomeness
as a fan of the show when you went on
the show and you and Benji got into it
was that kind of exciting as a fan
Drew's a bummer it was a bummer it was a
real bummer the wrap-up show is when we
really went at it right and we spent 21
it's whole bet there's some hold it yeah
we spent 20 minutes just screaming at
each other basically and I saw red it
was one of those moments where I was
like I felt that adrenaline I was like
am I gonna fight Benjy Bronk and the
wrap-up sound like that's not good I
feel bad about it I would someday like
to apologize the better because I don't
like attacking someone's manhood you
know what I mean like just eating them
at their job and in perhaps threatening
that you know I don't really understand
what it is he does there so I have no
place to say that and I'm just trying to
be funny
I think and I feel bad for 100% pain not
90 not 89 do something and ballers you
play this financial advisor who's really
more of sort of this backroom deal maker
kind of awfully guy you see like the
Kevin Durant go into Golden State maybe
you think about it differently because
you've kind of played a role as somebody
who does that behind-the-scenes thing I
wasn't listening to a word you were
saying oh it's changing in my mouth
Oh whole head it's it on a wipe
embrace the challenge what if I run out
of milk
we've got only 11 we got milk on deck
zoom in on my eyes shaking at the cheers
whoo how you feeling
you're tapping out ah unless you don't
know this is the bomb beyond insanity
hot sauce it is no joke
Rob you want them you're talking a big
game gonna know you can taste that it's
coming I got that's terrible
mm-hmm is the worst is this your
favorite shetland I'm running down my
face oh yeah real tears third time ever
only the third time every fluid in my
body is I just peed my pants that's a
hot ones first make sure not to put
these fingers on my eyeballs
Sam this is the worst thing I've ever
done tapping out Rob I don't want to
give up one more
I'm done I'm done I can't do it
you're doing the stop here but I'm here
but I can't live with it I'm done I'm
out [ __ ] that's name
so you chill I'm gonna eat and I'll just
ask you questions you just try to relax
over there
no Joe not wiping the tears away because
it's good that's good TV do you remember
the story behind your first fistfight or
maybe your most eventful fistfight and
it was quick to go down I got punched in
the face and they stole my lacrosse
stick I was just hitting balls against
the side of a wall all I want to talk
about is sauce right now all right
howdy so can't even imagine this is a
show we always have to apologize for
every time I know I think there's a best
idea for however you do I do
thanks for being here very good you
really were that you want to power
through those questions and I'm done
answering those questions always it
happens I'm just talking about my mouth
so this next one is Mad Dog 357 ready
I'll eat it if I can just loosely out of
jokes what if have you ever had anybody
throw up I think riff raff might have
and pass out I don't know if there'll be
a first why are you closed now
I was exaggerating for the mere purposes
I'm still but you don't go in saturating
that much I'm not a judgment how much it
hurts now to ask me questions about my
mouth how's your mob doing it's on fire
make a death sauce with you're not gonna
put more on that that's the tradition
around here we dab the last wing is not
a fun experience but it's one you got to
go through you know I did this yesterday
seen a window to my right that was
really excited I love wings all right so
I'm gonna take this bite let me ask you
a question okay I need a little advice
from you go ahead
can you tell me about coming to terms
with baldness because for a while there
you were like me where you were kind of
caught in this no-man's land
so yeah God give me some advice like
what when did that hit you were when I
comfortably I came to terms with it when
I was a little kid because every male in
my family is Bob some of the females of
all if I started losing it when I was
like 19 20 and I just wanted to go get
this part over you know kind of close
there you go beautiful maybe I should do
the same thing
you don't you have a full head of hair
yeah but it gets kind of like it's
starting to look like Florida that's
cool but it'll be to the back I'm going
to the top you're doing fine
how do you how are you doing with our
way somehow made it through yeah cleared
the board one of the most heavily sauced
episodes we've ever had unfortunately
for you Rob I was on a heavily sauced
episode the floor is yours this camera
or that camera let the people know what
you got going on in your life I don't
know I got nothing what do you got let's
do it let's do this mean
and also watch ballers in on HBO at
10:00 a.m. on Sunday ah easy no usually
I take some plug - I'm pretty blasted
out after this fire yeah I'm glad that
you're having trouble too
you